all right it's eight minutes past five
coming soon downtown Las Vegas is about
to see a new Performing Arts Center open
its doors it's the Beverly theater
filling a void for independent Arts
Candace Charles is live this morning
inside the Beverly with plans for
Premiere week in March Candace is an
exciting project
yes John it really is we know how
excited you are good morning to you good
morning folks all of you guys should be
excited excitement has been mounting
since the announcement was made a couple
of years ago here at this two-story
building you'll be able to see poetry
readings book readings and more they've
committed 30 million dollars towards the
Arts here in the community the Rogers
Foundation is behind all of this all
Beverly Rogers is brainchild really and
I have Kip Kelly from the Rogers
Foundation the creative director thank
you so much for joining us nice to have
you here thank you guys thank you we're
excited that you're excited as well so
hard and I know that the three pillars
are going to be behind the first week of
events right which is March 3rd when you
guys open tell us about those pillars
that really sets up the place here right
yeah so uh this is Las Vegas's first
true independent filmhouse and
performance theater and with that we've
put together what we think are three
unique pillars of programming that we
can offer we have a live program which
will be concerts and performances we
have a lit program which speaks to our
literary stuff and then we'll be not
really lit lit though right kind of lit
they are pretty lit I like that uh and
we also have our uh our film program
which is what we're anchored by so we'll
have independent film here seven days a
week
um and and
those three things really speak to what
the Beverly theater is all about
especially grand opening weekend amazing
okay tell us about grand opening weekend
you guys just announced it yesterday
we're standing out front here right guys
so you guys will be able to see this on
March 3rd yes so uh speaking a little
bit more to those pillars we have put
together a program that we think uh it
fits what the the community wants but we
think well people who live here Las
Vegas locals are looking for uh we have
um independent filmmakers uh from killer
films Oscar award winning uh they're
going to be here doing a q a they'll
also be debuting one of their films that
they just screamed during Sundance we
have a lot of great literary program
with our partners at the writer's block
next door and also Black Mountain
Institute they'll be bringing in some
authors and having some in conversations
and some book readings and signings uh
very cool
um and then uh Tuesday March 7th it all
caps off with uh Las Vegas's own Echo
who uh we think is uh the definition of
independent music success especially out
of Las Vegas he'll be headlining the
show here we're really excited for all
that awesome awesome thank you you so
much kit for joining us this morning and
for your enthusiasm we love it you guys
this is only the beginning as I said
we're standing outside throughout the
morning we'll be giving you a tour a
one-of-a-kind tour you can only get with
us on 8 news now you know I got you
uncovered with all the fun stuff of
course you guys can enjoy the week of
Debut March 3rd to the 7th is open to
and free to the public as well as after
RSVP we got you covered with the details
on our website itnewsnow.com for now
live from The Beverly leader I'm Candace
Charles 8 news now all right Candace
thank you very much very eager to look
inside next